hey there folks Chris Waters here
hosting the Shawn method sha mckinness
could not be with us because he's like
watch dogging his way around Chicago or
something or on vacation I don't know
what anyways uh today on the Sha method
we're going to play a game near and dear
to my heart it's called new nuar Throne
it's by vamer the Dutch developers who
made uh like Ridiculous Fishing and some
other game that I meant to look up ahead
of time and joining me on the stream is
going to be Bonito because Nuclear
Throne I've played it a bunch so I've
been on Early Access for many months now
but have not played the co-op yet Coop
and Bonito has never played the game
before except for like two minutes ago
so it's going to be fun join us as uh we
try to fight our way through the mutant
infested wastelands of whatever
apocalyptic scenario this is basically
Bonito you uh you move around your
little mutant character you kill all the
bad guys on the screen you can mutate
yourself to get like special powers from
level to level and you try to reach the
Nuclear Throne which will be impossible
but we're maybe going to try love a
dtick shooter all right yeah so we're
playing on Steam with Xbox 360
controllers and uh we're going to give
it a shot here think we can just do a
quick restart all right so here's the
menu you can start off there's a number
of mutants you can choose from uh let's
go through these so the first one is
fish fish has more ammo and can do a
Dodge roll every mutant has like a
passive is that like a dark souls
Dodge yeah yeah it's just like a roll a
tum it's more of a tumble across the
screen uh has like a passive thing and
an active thing so fish gets more ammo
can dodge roll Crystal has more HP o
dual wielding and can turn into a shield
yep you're talking about steroids
steroids who's a little hard to read low
like has more ammo less accurate but can
dual wield uh yv who's like this
triangle dude has high rate of fire
melting is an awesome character who I'm
going to play as in a little bit gets
more XP has very low Health but can also
uh trigger all the corpses on screen to
explode oh corpse explosion yes and it's
also named as a verb indeed and also
there's chicken who uh are those
unlockables those have yes and there's
more that we will unlock as we play uh
but I'm going to start as chicken the
Blindfolded ninja who can go in slow
motion and even if I get killed if I had
there's like you can run around with
your head cut off as chickens do and is
it like is it like opposite controls or
something like control no it's just like
it's just like where your the top of
your head was is a little bone sticking
out and if you get health during that
phase you come back to life does your
head come back out yeah your head comes
back out I'm going to play do wielding
dude because that sounds cool steroids
yeah so uh that means left trigger will
just fire both of your weapons as a and
uh that's my special or it'll
fire your secondary weapon and right
trigger fires your first one I don't
know you'll have to see all right let's
do this nuclear throw oh my God I am
very J yeah dude your name is steroids
and there ammo in this game right so you
can't just shoot everything yeah so I've
got a I've got this chicken sword and uh
I'm fighting my way through here picked
up a machine gun all that what's that
all that stuff that looks like cash is
that actually cash so that that little
green stuff is I think it's called like
DNA or something like that so it's it's
it's the fuel you use to to
um evolve all right so thing about melee
attacks is they can uh swipe away enemy
projectiles that's cool uh defense yeah
so it's it's it's a good uh defensive
move and chicken starts with his sword
should I be shooting at the walls and
finding Secrets no uh you can't destroy
walls with normal Munitions you can only
do that with uh explosives and I'm
pretty sure there are no secrets behind
walls but then again I haven't played
this game in a while and uh they've been
making a bunch of updates to it
including the uh the co-op that we are
now playing so we went into that portal
is that like uh is that the end of that
level or that that's the end of that
level uh so also like when I Gauntlet
that's so Gauntlet yeah it totally is
when I hit a corpse if you whack a
corpse and the corpse go into another
enemy it will damage them oh
excellent all right that thing's dead
why don't you go get
those so like Monster
DNA oh maggots so once you kill The Last
Enemy on screen that portal opens up so
if there are like chests around or if
you want like like weapons you want to
grab you want to try to do that before
open opens up
unless if the weapons are nearby they'll
get sucked into the portal as well no
that giant maggot is not cool so like if
there's one guy left in the map and he's
like in the very beginning you have to
go all the way back to kill him yes but
the maps aren't actually that big as you
probably noticed uh and there's all
right so this on the third map is you
heard that special music it's a big
Bandit is that a boss yeah so this is
like a little mini boss oh God so it's a
bad situation no
HP oh God there's another one up there
oh
oh he will like come on we got him he
will like charge through oh
[__] oh my goodness all right I got him
[__] me up but Bonito is dead I'll
Soldier on without you no B you have
questions for the chat I will be reading
them when I'm dead at twitch.tv/ gamot
now uh so I have three Health that's not
like a lot uh but you can there are ways
to get health and you can get some
mutated perks which we'll take a look at
once I finish this level cuz I uh have
leveled up but you only get to mutate in
between levels I'm going to keep the
grenade launcher not the machine
gun bam yeah eat it oh magot pile do not
like mag so this is still an early
access game right now right yes this is
an early access game but it is coming to
uh once they're finished with it it's
going to come to
PlayStation uh 3 for vaita cuz it was
actually at the PlayStation booth at E3
it was one of the many they had so all
right here's some so I come back at the
end do I come back in the next level I
don't think so I'm not sure there cuz I
haven't played this call before man yeah
uh so I get a few different mutations uh
there's a r there's a there's like a lot
of different ones but they give you a
random assortment of four every time you
level up so I get plus four Max
HP uh normal rate of fire during slow
motion enemies touching you take damage
kills lower your reload time so I don't
really shoot I like to play chicken as a
Melee character uh so enemies touching
me take damage is kind of good but
Throne butt so that's a the name that's
the name of the the thing which I'm not
sure you might need to have this
mutation to sit on the Nuclear Throne at
the end anyways that's always a
character specific one the rest of these
are character can get thr yeah so thrown
butt is like generally a pretty good way
to go um you usually want to get your
character specific one right because
yeah cuz it sort of leans into your
strengths and you can play to your
strength a little better however at
three out of eight health I if I I think
if I go plus4 Max HP it gives me plus4
as well oh yeah so so you'll be like
seven out of 12 yes so I'm tempted to go
there um I haven't actually used slow
motion yet so I'm going to go for extra
oh but I leveled up twice so now I can
do so that's a different set of stuff
yeah it's a different set of mutations
so you won't be presented with like the
same mutations you you have okay but
they will come back around if you pass
on them the first time and the it's
doing this weird doubling description
thing because we're in Co-op that's just
still a gains an early access yeah
that's an alpha thing stronger attract
power shells bounce further more speed
uh extra feet yeah I'm think I'm going
to go with extra feet does that happen
to your character model dude do you get
I don't think the character models
change actually they might I'm not sure
see it looks like the chicken just has
two feet still so I can do this is
slowmo now I'm on a a separate oh God I
forgot the rats take two hits all right
so this is like the level oh so it's
like a it's a new to set already yeah
the you the first three levels are
always that desert area then it's the
sewer level after this it's a after two
of these it's a junkyard and beyond that
I don't know uh so you see this purple
dude here oh he just slic the crap out
of me we got a jiron 666 in chat he says
he uh he writes the wiki for this game
no kidding awesome very helpful to have
go check that out no give me give me
some health ah all right so that was me
running around with my as a chicken with
my head cut off we did not reach the new
okay so what happens here like do we
have do we if it's restart we have to
start from the beginning weart from all
the way to the beginning oh so it's like
a do you want to change your character
or do you want to stick with uh steroids
I'll stick with steroids was cool all
right I'm not sure which so it's on the
controller it just resets it all right
so we unlocked a couple different ones
so now we have eyes who can see in the
dark you saw that sewer level was dark
and telekinesis you can pick stuff up
far away I think yeah I think it like
draws enemies and and uh weapons to you
uh so that you can grow oh so yeah plant
can shoot a uh snare out and it'll it'll
just sort of root an enemy temporarily a
hold and then
Rebel allies I think Rebel can call in
allies I'm not exactly like a friendly
buff but our Wiki maybe our wiky master
in the chat can uh give us a help with
that all right I'm going to go with
chicken one more time I'm down with
chicken yeah I'm going to go with d
because he was buff all right let's
stick with these guys we'll mix it up a
little bit we've got got stream to do it
all
right we take great care this time to
stay alive all right here come and get
this uh extra mutation
jar yeah we'll get mutation bucks get
some
steroids get steroids some steroids get
me some more steroids
some good
steroids none of that weak stuff so you
start off you have you are actually dual
wielding oh that sounds like a
scorpion oh yeah oh no I took one in the
face that was sloppy hell H so that's
yeah that's the you oh so it just sucks
you in yeah it sucks you in within a
certain radius that's a new melee weapon
oh it's a
crossbow but I have no bolts for it
and a crossbow comes empty that one that
one a Nuclear Throne crossbow nuclear
crossbow you can like hit enemies
through walls a little bit with uh a big
enough melee weapon which chicken has
Slugger yeah that's like a beefy one
slug shotgun I like
that get it pretty sure the skull is
nothing but notice it's a foury cow
skull weird
apocalypse laser pistol I mean I'll try
that out if it has any ammo I do like
the crossbow better oh no ammo crossbow
yeah so I guess the slowmo like does it
affect enemies cuz it should right like
that's the that sounds like the point
like max pain
Style watch out fsy
maggots do you know how many levels
there are all right so oh uh no but they
do show you like a progress bar at the
end at least all right so this is my I
get to choose first homing bolts more HP
from medkits some kills regenerate
HP full health and some ammo I'm going
to go with some kills regenerate H that
sounds good I don't know why did you get
that too cuz you should get it you
should have but I didn't see your cursor
making the choice cuz you were at two as
well yeah I don't know what that's about
oh see see I'm at Max HP already cuz of
that
perk all right I should oh shoot I was
looking at the wrong dude oh the big
guys here oh God there's so many it's a
big boss
man blast
him I
am blast
him oh God oh God oh God that was close
oh God all these little maggots oh damn
it oh yeah eat a
laser maggots but life is rough man it
is ah there's another one they make more
of those things I need this health
badly oh no where oh some kills regen
you're back you're back you're back
you're back you're back you're not
you're dead how did I come back how did
I come back maybe the large Health box
brought you back uh uh so yeah we made
it to the almost the second so there's
like one two three four five six seven
like eight levels yeah bad bad
scene I think we can finish this I think
we can finish this we got
it I'm not sure there's a quick restart
on the controller and uh Jon 666 who
does the wiki he says like Co-op is
still very much in in the works oh yeah
totally I think they just announced it
in like you know past month or two it
seems like totally functional though
like the game same place yeah there's
just you know there's little weirdnesses
I guess but it definitely is functional
all right I'm going to go with fish I'm
going to mix I'm going to go with
melting uh who is real weird no
wait so melting I have two health so I
start really low sounds like an anime
character but here Watch What Happens
like like I kill that those corpses come
up here next to me boom oh okay okay so
you can blow them up to like
oh watch out for that maggot coming back
up and like these that makes these
maggot dudes like just bombs oh [__] so
does that hurt me I don't think so I
don't think it does here go stand on
that
maget false
science nope didn't hurt
you come
on do you have the
Slugger oh so see this uh this is a see
how it's got junk on it it's one of
those uh you got to shoot that first
yeah oh wow okay yep so a lot of them
come out but then I you can I did the
like corpse bomb and they all just yeah
your thing is perfect for that oh God
scorpion yes the Slugger doesn't go
super
far not a
rage there you go level two level two
fish let's see your
Dodge that's pretty
big how does that work does that have a
cool down I can just keep doing it I
don't know I can just keep doing it give
it a
shot that's how I should just move
around the
map if you can if you can handle the
fish
speed that's ammo I can roll like a
fish rolling rolling fish roll and boom
boom explode all yall
suers all right so that's the last guy
so we want to kill him and then break
this
thing all right we're both level two so
we should both get to upgrade your
cursor is not there it works also I
think it's a party upgrade oh okay all
right well which one do you want L's
energy weapons deal more damage stronger
attract power so it draws the uh the
green bits to you longer melee range or
more speed I would go with speed cuz
that's like an allaround right like
everybody can use more speed I'm down
with
it yeah see Walts is saying this game
doesn't really scream Sean methoding and
it's true this is more of a multiple
players it's true but Shawn abandoned us
all so blame Shawn also there was some
we were we were planning a little bit to
like try to stream the new Hearthstone
update uh during this slot cuz it was
maybe going to drop pretty early on I
died I'm dead I am so dead it's all you
watch out for the big Bandit yep that's
that's
your low
shells I hope they don't give you two
big Bandits they
might like I said I was saying before
folks we were going to maybe try to
stream the Hearthstone uh new nice
evasion uh update but it's not live yet
so we're going to be maybe taking a look
at that a little later on it's live now
says Eric Tay hollering from the
bizak so uh T you downloaded
it because we have Tay work in the
Stream he hasn't downloaded it yet oh
gotcha um but we'll get it downloaded
we'll check it out for you folks stay
resurrect your Co-op friend there should
be a medkit in the next level yeah so
that's what that's what I that's when
you came back that second time all right
I'm going to
stick with melt I'm going to go with
melting St s this is only two players
right it's only two players for now yes
I believe that's correct did we unlock
anyone yet no it say I guess we have to
reach scrapyard to unlock this guy
question mark question mark to unlock
that guy I take HP HP let's go with some
defense all right so that you that's
your thing like you turn into a crystal
like that oh it's like a I think you
temporarily turn invulnerable it's like
a uh litu not litu
that Mario costume Tanuki there you go
let's try it out that what does that do
oh it B oh cool it reflects oh that it
okay okay oh that was kind of cool okay
I can hang with
that no no wow I think you just saved my
life
no we're talking like this scw driver
yeah it's a melee weapon it's like this
it's it's like very the the radius is
not very good but the length is pretty
decent although melting with melee is
not like the
smoothest oh God I just got maggot
merked lame oh you only have two HP yeah
[__] melting starts with really low
HP very uh
dangerous I like this guy like oh [__]
all the corpses must
explode need flashbacks of Diablo
2 watch out for these
incoming oh I have no ammo
[__] so if I have no ammo I'm just kind
of screwed yep pretty
much uh why don't you get that Health
there this yellow one is ammo ah I got
some ammo I got
some I need to do more exploding all
right we got some
bullets all right so if it's going to be
for both of us my Throne butt is bigger
explosions yours is but it says melting
in parenthesis yeah but it ALS so that's
so maybe it should be thrown but for
both but it's only showing
me I don't
know all right I'm going to choose throw
Alpha [__] yeah that might be some still
in Early
Access
deal maybe the wiki guy can help us out
with
that explosion is like whoa where am I
over there boom boom melting corpse
explosions oh melting is
dead look at that it teleport it
teleports me I that was weird I think if
I don't fit in the top where I at it's
it teleports you oh you're right next to
the B dude pick up that machine gun
press
X oh oh jeez I thought you were dead
nope nope Staying Alive nice work
there oh hopefully I can get that uh
medkit talking about yeah the one that's
uh
in the next
level there we go so you have now two
weapons that use bullets you're going to
have a slugger the option to pick up a
slugger on the next one so you might you
could which uses [__] which uses shells
so you could consider diversifying your
load up yeah load out but yeah oh so
they Ed oh they use different ammos so
you right now I'm on the same ammo type
on my okay
yeah full health and some am
what fly and corpses fly and hit harder
better accuracy better all
right this is family that's your
family all right so some things to watch
out for on this level uh rats move
pretty
quickly those uh oh God I like green
those green uh barrels explode and leave
an a my it puts it where my reticle is
puts me where my reticle is I was just
experimenting and I died did you
teleport onto that thing or did you
blast it I think I teleported into it oh
not pretty not pretty at all all right
melting your explosions are wonderful
but I think I'm going to go back I
really love chicken but I guess we
should show some different people so
I'll try
Rebel who has defense and
allies or the plant play the
plant n
growth oh it's like that okay
an environmental hazard
yeah ooh okay so I have an all we have
an ally now oh oh summon that guy think
it cost two Health though is he bleeding
like he's bleeding he might be slowly
dying come on Ally get in the mix don't
go Dy in right
away grenade launcher
oh yeah my Ally is dead Okay that was
maybe he just slowly bleeds out he's
timed I don't know if the defenses maybe
I take less yeah he probably does slowly
maybe he takes the bullets for you or
something I don't know what I wonder if
the the mod or the the wiki mod guy give
me some insight into what defense means
maybe I take one damage instead of two
in certain
situations
W oh empty grenade launcher bad
news got you suck
it yeah
yeah oh are you empty [__] I just took
those bullets H this this yellow box
come up
here there you go and then there's
another
one you have a second weapon you should
get that laser
pistol it's empty but one day it may be
full Bam
Bam all right I got to stop grabbing
ammo cuz we are low yeah I'm just cuz
I'm just shooting I need to conserve my
ammo that I
got oh crap I'm cool I'm cool it's cool
don't worry about it it's cool good
we're good we're
good uh-oh we're not good there's a big
big
bad
eat it grenade
launcher he's stuck there you should be
at least yeah he's dead we got big
Bandit down all right I got
some go through wall go get down and get
that ammo go down go down go down go
down go down get that ammo no all right
up here up here yellow Bo up here all
right you got laser oh nice you snare
one of those
dudes oh no I walked right into it okay
so defense is when I get
injured I think I shoot out that radius
of energy
stuff laser gun's good yellow ammo box
up
here right I'm going to get the disc gun
so people can this G where do that
bounce boun around it's it's a little
it's a little dangerous it's like the
the Razer gun from Unreal Tournament the
one that bounces on the walls oh God
yeah all right here I'll show you guys
it's uh oh sorry I had to flee oh gosh
okay we got all the stuff the disc did
its job was it the disc that got him I
don't know all right can you so you
can't move this is oh you can so it's
both of
us higher Ally rate of
fire melee range neither of us really
has a melee weapon some kills regenerate
ammo no damage from explosions and fire
when under 50%
health I haven't seen that many
explosions or fire well you would but
we're going Throne butt feel like Throne
but's a good
default okay the rats take a few more
bullets the disc gun is really dangerous
in this
level can you hurt yourself with it I
think you I'm pretty sure you
can at least the last time I played the
game all right see that's an assassin
that guy sleeping oh [__]
okay very dangerous
my snare stuff doesn't work very well in
these hallways oh no yeah you can't go
through walls I need line of
sight you see any green rats when you
kill them they will probably
explode is that your oh yeah oh big
nasty rat was vomiting out rats that's
how rats reproduce right by vomit yeah I
think we should ask
Mary
bazooka yes I don't know what a pop gun
is are you taking the
Bazooka yikes I'm going to take the pop
gun I probably shouldn't fire that at
Point Blank all right hey we got past
this one popgun also shoots bullets yeah
all right so these oh God I'm
God okay yeah we made it to that level
all right yikes I took one shot with a
bazooka and killed myself oh you
did okay yeah I got swarmed by crowman
Crow
demon all right
Rebel I'm not so down with the defense I
love chicken I'm going chicken this time
again yeah I think did we stay everybody
we everybody right we haven't everybody
we unlocked robot Rob find better Tech
and eat guns yeah you eat guns and get
ammo so if there's like guns you don't
want gun no one wants empty guns even
you eat whatever gun you have equipped
oh I'll play robot we'll see some Robo a
triangle or what is this guy called
pyramid
yv okay I think it's a I think it's a
she
also I'm not sure I'm noticing like a
Japanese Tendencies you know like
melting that sounds like a very anime
name as
well
oh God stepping
directly I can shoot with my I only have
one gun right now and I can do shotgun
shot yeah a shotgun
shot that's
it oh okay so I can't go
check maggots oh God oh
God
oh I took a hit robot man took a hit eat
your gun I'm want to go get that
ammo you should get that gun
too get out of my face maggot I'm not
having it I see you creeping on my robot
self there ain't no organic material
here for you to Feast on you filthy
maggot worm thing gross as
hell
nasty
oh yeah I'm going to I'm going
to I'm going to eat my
pistol I got Max HP for eating my
pistol see before we were playing there
was a situation in which we had two
reticles on this area I feel like
anyways better gun nutrition attract
stronger stronger attack power some
kills generate ammo more HP from medkits
you got preference um I think killing
gives you HP because that like Keep Us
Alive longer no this is killing gives
you ammo oh gives you ammo yeah I don't
know no real
preference but better wait you Throne
butt
yeah but oh God uhoh I took a lot of
shots got
you
watch
out oh my God that dude had me in a
corner yeah that was a bad
situation f is this assault Slugger that
sounds
snarly you want to get assault slugged
that's what it means when that's oh eat
it eat it this is my better tech oh
robot
life assault
Slugger
nasty all right Bonito I'm going to save
you me some Med kit
action freaking rat get over
here fre
rats creep up behind me I see
you I'm reading chat so let me know if I
come back
alive I
will oh eat it rats eat it so bad
yeah L
bull L bull people asking yes there's
going to be ComiCon live shows for three
days so much Thursday Friday Saturday
take that I want to say four to six but
I'm not
sure 4 to 6 yeah it's 4 to 6 okay there
you go 4 to 6 Thursday Friday Saturday 4
to 6 live shows we got all kinds of
demos coming out of ComicCon I saw the
list looks pretty good I don't think I
can talk about it but it looks pretty
good yeah I'm not sure oh gosh the rats
there's too many triple machine gun to
the rescue nice what's that big gun on
your back that's my assault Slugger I
think or this might be my triple machine
gun this is my triple machine
gun NE I will find you I will resurrect
you save me
Chris am i r still
there yeah so it's like a spread fire
machine gun which is not super useful in
these narrow
corridors oh it eats up ammo it does
yeah that's a problem with this like
really good Tech
yeah oh where's the one rat that I
didn't kill
yet or the other health pack thing that
I can save Bonito
with there
is there was supposed to be a health
back on this level mod
friend but I did not find it next that's
right I'll get you next time higher ammo
Max corpses fly and hit harder better
accuracy enemies touching you take
damage yeah accuracy or fly and hit hard
fly and hit harder cuz we haven't seen
that yet yeah this one is pretty good
actually they bouncer out around like
crazy God that gun is crazy [__] oh my
god oh fire oh fire where are it's a
freaking fire lizard look at that thing
he you like an arc like there're two of
those guys well that's a so it's that's
a fire trap which happens on these
levels that car explodes if you shoot it
this guy at the top running around uh
with a little cowboy hat and a sniper
rifle is a sniper and then there's this
fire lizard thing which I've never seen
before the hell you supposed to was
terrifying what are you supposed to do
right there that's crazy I don't know
maybe I should have assault slugged them
assault slug I I like I the like I think
I played them all already at this point
I mean the shield guy and the Dodge guy
we haven't seen eyes yet I'll play as
eyes in the dark and has telekinesis
that seems only useful in that one level
yeah Dody I'm going to go with the Dodge
guy fish fishing it up yes so like yes
come closer to
me you 3D glasses
yep I got hit already [__] come on fish
they
Frosty bang you know what gets me though
is that there's a lot of like screen
jolting oh damn it go oh yeah from like
explosions and stuff yeah a little
confusing I'm sure it's the kind of
thing you get used to over time oh get
the bullets go up there and get the
bullets you crazy bullet man
that's a oh [__] pretty good burn huh
crazy bullet man yeah take
that go pick up that ammo you
desperately need
it oh God oh
God what's that that thing looks like
it's going to explode I don't
know Pi it up I have low bll oh I opened
it I don't know what happened I don't
know what I got from it 60 bullets
that's good cuz I had low bull more
speed stronger attract power no damage
from explosions fire 15% Health most hit
bullets become ammo most hit bullets
become ammo I think you I think we need
that one for you Bonito yeah I decl so
if you hit somebody it turns it out like
what does that mean does he drop am oh
that's see one bullet yeah
okay yeah so we well oh God low HP low
HP
you want a machine
gun at least have another gun all right
we'll find you a health
pack oh God great bullets oh God there's
another guy here there a bandit
here sticking him with the crossbows oh
god oh what he can destroy terrain oh
yeah did you not notice that damn it I
didn't notice that yeah he totally can
destroy terrain all right forget
telekinesis it's chicken ninja time
I feel like I didn't get the most out of
my Dodge there yeah I I find myself like
forgetting to use the the things
sometimes yeah come to my slowmo
Zone it'll slow down I guess it slows
down enemies and projectiles like close
to me oh damn
it why I got that Health Pi up just then
got you
sucker hope you got some of those
bullets all right yeah you got all those
bullets
good chicken with a crossbow and no ammo
all different ammo Types on the ground
too oh God
okay I I didn't even notice in the
ground the ammo pickups are different
types
yes yes they
are
big bullet pack for big bullet
spenda oh no none of that ammo oh [__]
oh fish Dodge you're in a tight spot
fish you're good you're good you're good
you want to get that laser
pistol yeah laser p badass yeah because
it goes through enemies right and it's
like super
accurate High ammo damage taken is dealt
to All Enemies on screen damage taken oh
it's like Thorns sharp
teeth uh plutonium hunger stronger
attract power or I want to go for M plus
melee
range steroids can do wield it's so
weird when you read that out of context
so look at how long I can hit I can hit
like oh I can those
guys he go through walls yeah it
does eat it
maggots oh the bad guy the big bad guy
oh God there's another one up there
[__] sorry that's what I meant by the
big bad
guy oh there's a bunch of
them
he's dead oh I'm dead I need help oh get
that Health oh no you took it all right
Dead Oh I thought you were dead already
I was dead I told you I was dead that's
why you thought I was dead but then I
realized I was playing as chicken oh he
stays alive so yeah he stays alive he
can get his head back on oh god oh
that's right there he is there's his
head all right fish
got this fish is going to take it what
what gun is that down to the
left right there that flashing thinga
let's see that that's the same bullets
and it's just going to waste my bullets
even faster now it is definitely
is don't forget fish dodging fish
dodging nice
shots present might have uh ammo in it
27 bolts congratulations you do not have
a crossbow I did drop a crossbow back
there oh I roll through that I roll
through that I don't know if you can
roll through I guess not like I think
that you can you don't like you still
get hit if you're rolling it's just a
pure Evas it's just a a quick evasion
yeah not as cool as I thought then I'm
going to go with the crystal Shield
guy yeah you were enjoying the crystal
Shield a little earlier chcken it was
because like I had lots of presence of
mine to use gra that know like to use
this thing there's like a lot of
presence in mind you're about to die
ah
ah also you have 10 Health good starting
yeah that's kind of useful for a guy
that gets hit a
lot oh and we're
done that was quick theing
strong minimize damage taken hold on I
can yeah I can kill those maggots
through the wall all right go ahead and
grab that ammo
in your face in your face in your face
oh God
okay okay oh God I am a oh my God I'm
okay we got to get out of here sh we got
to get out of here B holy [__] it's
crazy okay okay
okay
okay what the
[__]
chicken oh no too
many God there's so many bullets yeah
it's those scorpions oh God I'm been in
bad
shape like two scorpions they're down
they're down they when they were out of
phase there was just like bullets
everywhere yeah I
know eat it there we go there we
go okay okay there's a crossbow or yeah
maybe the same ammo though yeah
I bad Health situation
that's fine oh okay we both have three
Health we should have both I should have
leveled up there but I didn't maybe we
both G oh yeah maybe still alpha or beta
I don't know what they're calling it
it's early access so it's still in
progress they I think they're about
halfway done all right there's a big
Health thing down there if you want to
grab
it maybe we should wait to grab it in
case one of us
dies whatever I don't actually know how
that would work
nice deflection like
that got him okay grab that one yeah now
we talking healthy again all right come
back down here I think there might be
some stuff yeah there's a slugger I
already have a
slugger there's ammo for
him all right eat it ninja sword chicken
slice
oh
yeah murder
murder boom got you all
right all right kills lower your reload
time more HP from medkits more speed
plus four Max HP that's reload time I
guess like cool down of his
shots uh well like yeah it's cool down
of your shots so like the crossbow the
bigger weapons you can only fire so
often but I think it's a fire basic
let's go plus four Max H yeah let's do
that we're going to get further Amateur
hour is
over give here a rat sh
rat chickens and rats are natural
enemies watch out for that fat guy I
think he explodes like a boomer oh yeah
got him though can you not pass through
the
gem I
can I can roock off CH points and [__]
like that
that that's a good call stay away stay
away damaging
travels so yeah this is where you'd have
where eyes the T the telekinesis dude
would have a higher sight radius like
basically you see the black right
yeah
yeah the Slugger bullets ricochet which
is kind of cool there's an assault rifle
here I don't know if you want
it eat it
rats oh of course it's a B I was like oh
where's The Last Enemy all I see is that
freaking chest that was so stupid one HP
oh my God Bonito one HP all right some
kill regenerate HP I think is the
no-brainer here yeah there you go oh God
that was terrible all right this is a
really hard level oh
God freck I got sliced oh God I'm
dead I am dead Bonito I know what I'm
supposed to kill yeah there is this is
this is a more Vis visually busy level
oh it's a bird it's a bird all right so
you have you should maybe pick up a
sword you have have like two bullets and
one
bullet but use the do not hit the car
with your sword I don't think is a good
idea
yeah nice
deflection talking about yeah oh God oh
God oh okay I made it I made it okay
you're fine you're
fine it help it I got you you're in
you're in you're in I'm out so you got
to get me back tag out all right
chickens got to regroup maybe grab a
weapon maybe I have some ammo for
no no I have no weapon ammo for either
of those I'm going to pick the
Slugger chicken
time what
the guy looks like a great dude melee no
fre
sniper yeah take that fire
lizard
there's this one guy man he he took me
out
too that guy oh that's right you can't
kill him with a sword because they
explode I forgot about that you're still
alive without your head you're still
alive God damn it I forgot about that
they're cuz they're
robots so if you slice them so when they
no matter what you kill them when they
explode yes I believe so damn okay all
right that was good though yeah that was
a good run that was a good combo team
chicken chicken Crystal the crystal Chi
yeah Crystal chicken
ride boom bang feeling feeling confident
got some ammo there for let's do this CH
ammo up here for
you that is pretty much nothing I think
it's just don't waste your bullets on it
I think it's just a environmental thing
that you can smash the crap out
of oh cool I have a screwdriver and a
sword
now boom
nice that's my new strategy run up to
them and turn into a pistol and then
start
shooting oh crap oh crap that was very
key oh yeah so there's like a souped
up uh scorpion guy over
here's like double the sh we got him now
nice that without some damage ow
okay all right we got out of that
one oh blow him up blow him
up oh god oh [__] oh
God I do not have any projectile
weapons oh my
god oh crap there's a bandit big Bandit
on the scene he just plowed me over I am
dead oh God that was cruel was terrible
those bonus those like Elite scorpions
Yeah man they like shower you with
bullets those dudes are bad that was bad
news bad news dudes okay uh give Crystal
chicken Team Crystal chicken Rides
Again
may we were a little too Cavalier that
time yeah feeling a little too strong
all right that's a big ammo box you
should probably grab
it
that oh a bad guy in there oh [__] I
didn't even know was thought it was a
Gun there's a melee weapon in
there
give me them chips
okay not having it maggots I'm straight
up not having
it not today
maggots y build them
maggots this gun you probably need a
oh dang it I was talking crap to maggots
and then I got
maggot huis man uh some kills regenerate
HP or plus four Max HP I feel like the
some kills regenerate HP is a good one
to to Sock
away probably a good first get all right
I've got I've got a grenade launcher you
only got 18 grenades though yeah that's
fine I'm going to change out my screw
driver oh look at that I like that just
send that out there oh son of a oh [__]
okay oh [__] it was fire on that okay
okay okay don't worry you sliced me up I
will bring you back you sliced me up
cruy you got to dis you got to slice
this guy up man this is where your you
need to ride the disc
gun it will kill you too I
believe it'll red oh do oh god oh
gosh learn learning okay learning about
bladed disc sh uh I think we just just
Spam through it both chose random all
right I'm steroids I am YX XY YZ what's
y y v y
v all right we
got oh
God steroid is already down to one HP
steroids is not doing so
H so only a little
bit steroids already has a
shotgun steroids only prefers to
steroids in the third person yeah
steroids is only fun in the third
person ooo steroids got some health but
then promptly lost
it oh see oh [__] I have I have no ammo
for either of my guns so I'm pretty
useless right
here steroids has died so that you may
live box oh
God he dead is he dead nice dodging is
he dead nice
dodging you're through you got it Well
Done random
spawn challenging
yeah those guys just flood the whole
scene oh
God trapped I try all right yeah all
right no no butt spamming to
random Ching you're my man or my lady
gender indeterminate not appear to be a
rooster my hand my H
girl is that is that going to be your
new
one watch your wife that way what's up
my
hen in there oh maggots sorry I hit the
maggot thing while you were close to it
to turn out
okay always surprise me even if I know
they're coming D get a bite of me
can you shoot through me Sho through uh
I don't know let's see that' be a pretty
good tactic we can handle
this yes I appear to be able to
shoot that is a good
attack m mhm you should get that
weapon there's bullets up
here into the tube the Doom tube full
health and some ammo most bullets become
most hit bullets become ammo damage
taken dealt to All Enemies on screen
stronger attract power I go the ammo one
probably like yeah hits turn into
ammo wind hurts all right this is the
level with the big Bandit so keep an eye
out for you're out for music changes and
an eye out for a music I didn't
notice son of a [__] okay wait yeah let
me make a wall let me make a
wall go shoot
him I don't have I wasn't shooting I
don't know why I thought I pressed the
button shoot
him it didn't like it like it didn't let
me shoot through you or a second oh God
all right it's dead it's dead it's
dead there he
is oh damn
it
woohoo gotcha
sucker get overwhelmed by the
bullets
so like yeah smash some of these guys
come on
closer you can hear them like bashing
against each other a little bit and it's
very
satisfying those scorpions are no joke
seriously I do not need to well all
right homing bolts no lower your reload
time normally to fire slow motion rate
of higher rate of fire as HP gets
lower butt thrown butt all
right so see like Sledgehammer has a
different hit radius it's it's good if
you don't have chicken sword but I'm
pretty sure chicken sword is a better it
gives you that anyway it's like you see
the hit sort of marked there
Sledgehammer is pretty much the same but
without throwing butt it's B right
probably like if you didn't if you just
didn't have chicken cuz chicken starts
with the chicken sword oh that's
right think so
rats yeah all
right sucessful
revive watch out for that
guy
are you what no you only have a pistol
and the whatever gun you have I had two
guns already you don't have your you
just got resurrected but your guns
didn't come back believe is the
case be gone
rat demon is this as far as we got yeah
this is it all right
yeah those chick oh [__] [__] cars
man oh yeah reflective bullets killed
you sucker
oh get it damn
cars I was like at full health and it
destroyed
me got go around
here oh nice
got you robot a little bit of right back
at
you yeah they have Uzi the crow men so
they shoot in burst of threee I
believe got a laser side sh
too oh God did I take that to the face
from just a rando regular piece of all
right
fine got this
Chris through the wall swords through
the
wall that was close
close give me Health give me Health you
sons of [__] made is it going to keep
me Al look at my dead little chicken
there might be a there might be
a what happen saving roll on any of
these more HP for medkits lower your
reload time weapon energy weapons deal
more damage higher
muscle oh man come on
baby dead there's the health it was so
close oh no a chicken I think we're at
time Team Crystal chicken made it to the
scrapyards and not much further what
that 31 32 or four well that I think
it's four cuz there's three desert one
sewer and then you go out into the scrap
yard or whatever that place is called
and our friend jiren 666 who writes the
wiki for this game says Uh there's going
to be a co-op update next week so they
might address all those little bugs that
we were cool running into yeah so that's
Nuclear Throne it's available on Steam
Early Access currently for like about 13
bucks I think uh but they also do sales
on it from time to time uh it's going to
be coming out on the PlayStation systems
once it's complete so in a little bit uh
and uh yeah thanks for watching here on
the Sha method coming up in just two
hours here on GameStop we've got the
lobby and on the lobby we've got some
cool games that I can name the crew
right the crew that's right ubisoft's uh
open world MMO racer thing the necro
dancer thing Crypt of the necro dancer
dungeon crawling with a DDR twist and uh
one more game in there that I can't
quite remember something else oh yeah
Oddworld new and tasty be on that one
it's going to be a great show we
probably should have put the hearstone
thing on there we'll do that later on
today maybe we'll squeeze it in we'll
see we'll see you back here in two hours
folks thanks for watching catch you
later
bye